you know Trump and some of his friends  keep saying oh if I'm president again  I'm going to ban men in women's sports  and Kerry Lake and all these other  people say we're going to ban men and  women's sports we will also keep  men out of women's sports  do they really have the authority to do  that and what I mean is can a president  regulate how a sports League operates  and how tournaments operate because that  doesn't really sound like small  government and it actually sounds like  extremely large intrusive government  it's not clear to me they can even  legally do it never mind whether it's  the business of government anyway